the big man of Ahsoka so far revealed a
connection to a group that Clone Wars
fans know well but folks who have
watched the animated Star Wars shows
also know that she should probably hate
who she's working for warning spoilers
for the first three episodes of Ahsoka
ahead
even in just its first few episodes
Ahsoka drops a lot of new Star Wars lore
there are ancient forced temples there's
a mysterious gateway to an entirely new
Galaxy there are orange lightsabers and
hidden Imperial spies but perhaps most
surprising of all is the twist at Morgan
elspeth the enigmatic villain first
introduced in the Mandalorian is
actually a night sister of dathomir what
was this place
an ancient temple built by my ancestors
the night sisters of daphnea this
Revelation isn't entirely out of left
field Morgan's Mandalorian appearance
revealed that she's one of the final
survivors of her people and chose her go
toe-to-toe the socatano in a duel
combine those interesting tidbits with
her eccentric look and some fans might
have been able to guess that Morgan was
actually a night sister but it does
raise some questions Morgan has served
the empire for years and has a strong
relationship with grand Admiral thrawn
if you've seen Star Wars the Clone Wars
you may find that more than a little
confusing darcidius himself considered
the night sisters one of the greatest
threats to his Reign and he ordered them
to be wiped out at face value Morgan's
role within Palpatine's regime makes no
sense shouldn't she hate the emperor and
his Empire dathomir has a long and
storied history in the Star Wars
Universe the mystical planet was first
introduced in the 1994 expanded universe
novel The courtship of Princess Leia
along with the night sisters at the time
these magical beings were referred to
only as four switches when dathomir was
given a more Central role in Star Wars
the Clone Wars they got their new name
the Clone Wars details how asajj
Ventress Count Dooku's Sith assassin
left her night sister commune on
dathomir and its powerful leader mother
talzin to serve the separatists after
being scorned by her new master Ventress
returns to dathomir and hatches a plot
of engines talzin makes herself a thorn
in the sides of both the Republic and
the separatists earning the attention of
Darth Sidious himself through a series
of conflicts in the Clone Wars and the
Darth Maul son of dathomir comics tells
it and the Knight sisters are
effectively wiped from existence
Palpatine sees them as an immense threat
due to their powerful dark force magic
so he removes them from the galactic
board so to speak so how did a Survivor
from this brutal Purge find her way into
the welcoming arms of the Empire if
Palpatine had any inkling of her true
Heritage you'd think he'd want to take
her out quickly and quietly and it's not
like she's some low-level stooge Morgan
was apparently crucial in constructing
the Imperial Fleet that thrawn used to
subdue the Galaxy during the Clone Wars
her people were massacred she survived
and let her anger fuel an industry which
helped build the Imperial Starfleet but
Palpatine is the one who killed Morgan's
people in the first place so why would
she align with this regime maybe like so
many she just never realized that
darcidius and the emperor were one in
the same though that's also kind of a
stretch the one thing that would make
this all make sense is thrawn himself as
a non-human the famed Grand Admiral was
an anomaly in the Imperial Navy
Palpatine's entire Empire was famously
racist toward aliens most of whom were
never allowed in it thrawn earned his
spot despite this and he could have used
his influence to help Shield Morgan
given her total loyalty to him in Ahsoka
that seems like a likely explanation
despite the questions it raises the
twist that Morgan ellsbeth is a night
sister is also really fun it brings a
key piece of Clone Wars lore into Ahsoka
which primarily pulls from Star Wars
Rebels and it sets up a lot of potential
after thrawn Returns the Knight sisters
might not be as famous as the Jedi or
the Sith but they're still incredibly
powerful if Morgan survives to see
thrawn come back she could be a strong
Aid to him we already know that she's a
brutal leader and skilled tactician but
now Ahsoka has thrown some dark magic
into the mix too it's unlikely that a
larger night sister presence will pop up
in Ahsoka since most of them were killed
back in the Clone Wars but anything is
possible the show is also revealed that
the night sisters had temples on planets
besides dapomir so there are a lot of
places where Creator Dave filoni and his
team could continue to expand their
Legend
[Music]